hello and welcome to all of you thank
you for coming tonight I must say after
Hannah's introduction I can't say that
the newspapers seem to think there is a
more important topic in the world at the
moment other than Fidelity and Affairs
as I think we've witnessed over the past
few weeks nevertheless I am Jenny
Russell I'm a columnist for the evening
standard and the Sunday Times and when I
was asked to chair this I thought about
the remarkable fact that in my adult
life as a journalist and political
commentator I don't think I've come
across any topic that has the capacity
to re to divide and enrage people so
much as a topic of how we should bring
up our children and even the current
debates over Affairs or whether Ken
Clark should be sacked or whether Fabio
Capello should beat him to
it don't interest people half as much as
the private question of whether they're
bringing up their children properly are
they best pushed to their
limits or should they be left to their
own devices to find out who they are as
people to investigate their own
personalities and to find their own
codes of
behavior I have to say that um for 18
months I lost a friend after her small
daughter turned up to my daughter's
birthday party and then proceeded to
spend most of the party leaning over the
table and scooping the icing off the top
of the birthday cake with her fingers
and then licking them and when I told
her to stop and behave herself my friend
stormed out of the house and didn't come
back again
and I have to say that in many years of
debating race and class and politics and
religion with my friends I'd never lost
one until that
point the format of tonight is going to
be that as usual I'm going to announce
the results of the way you initially
voted when you came into the hall and
I'll do that at the end of the opening
speeches and then we're going to take
the second vote as the concluding
speeches are being made and after the
question and answer session from the
floor and I'd just like to remind you
how how to cast your vote in case you
don't know you tear your ticket in half
and you put either the for or against
slip into The Ballot Box unless you're
still undecided in which case you post
the entire
ticket well I can't really believe that
there are going to be many of you who
are undecided at the end of listening to
tonight's panel and I hope this is going
to be a pretty contentious discussion
and the first Speaker for the motion is
Amy cheer the year law professor whose
somewhat Ry Memoir of her fanatical
Chinese parent parenting style battle
him of the tiger mother has been a
sensational hit on both sides of the
Atlantic and it's made her a heroine to
some people and a complete hate figure
to others and the most remarkable thing
I find about this is that Amy says she
had absolutely no idea she was going to
get any reaction to it she wrote it as a
literary Memoir and didn't foresee that
people were going to take it off as a
kind of personal stamp of approval or
disapproval of the way they raised their
own children I must say I think Amy's
image of turning her small daughter out
into the snow because she wouldn't do
her piano practice is one that's pretty
Unforgettable I'd now like to welcome
Amy to start tonight's
[Applause]
debate thank you so much Jenny and thank
you all for coming this evening let me
first very clearly State my position to
the extent that I believe Western
parents don't know how to bring up
children I also believe Chinese parents
don't know how to bring up children
we're all struggling to get it right
there are many ways of being a good
parent and I absolutely do not think
that Chinese mothers are superior
contrary to a certain newspaper headline
that you may have seen which I never
approved and do not agree with in fact
when it comes to child rearing I think
that Asia and the West have opposite
problems in general Asian child
wearing can be too strict too harsh and
too stifling whereas in general I think
Western parenting has become too
permissive and too indulgent and battle
hym of the tiger mother is really about
my own struggle to find a balance
between eastern and western Parenting by
way of quick background I was raised
Myself by extremely St
but also extremely loving Chinese
immigrant parents and the approach
worked with me I had a wonderful
childhood and to this day I adore my
parents um we voluntarily vacation with
them every chance we get which I think
is saying a lot and I feel that I owe
them everything which is why even though
my husband is not Chinese I wanted to
raise my own two daughters sopia and
Lulu the same way that my parents raised
me me with my first daughter Sophia
things went smoothly and I got cocky but
then my second daughter Lulu came along
and I got my comeuppence she is a real
Fireball we have very similar
personalities I feel she was born saying
no we locked horns from day one and the
book is actually filled with zany show
Downs I want to just uh say I never put
my daughter out in the cold actually
what happened is I said if you don't
stop banging on the piano I'm going to
put you out there in the cold and Lulu
true to her personality stepped out and
faced me defiantly and the end of that
chapter is me bribing her back with hot
chocolate and marshmallows to make her
come back in um so we fought a lot but
she always came back but then at age 13
something very different happened Lulu
rebelled not in a funny way she became
very angry very alienated seemed to turn
against everything I stood for and the
CL X of my book is a terrible public
fight in Moscow Red
Square I'm not going to give it away
but the most uh terrible things that
have ever been said to me were said
there um and Lulu threw a glass broke a
glass and said I you know I hate you I
hate this
family you're a terrible mother you're
selfish everything you say you do for me
is actually for yourself you make me
feel terrible about myself so for those
of you who haven't read the book I'm
pretty tough on myself um but it was a
horrible uh experience and at that very
moment it suddenly uh hit me that oh my
God I might lose my daughter and when
that hit me nothing else mattered I
don't care about school or grades or the
violin and that's when I changed uh not
completely um I still refus to
compromise on academic uh excellence and
many things but but I pulled back I let
Lulu drop the violin to do what she
wanted which at the time was to play
tennis I really loosened up socially she
has a Facebook an iPod uh the kids had
four sleepovers in the last two months
um something I'm not happy at all about
so Battle himym of the tiger mother is
the story of my own Journey as a mother
it was never intended to be a parenting
guide or a Sally into the mommy Wars
with all that said the book does have a
point of view while I certainly have
regrets if I had to raise my girls all
over again I would basically do the same
thing with some adjustments so um I'm
not saying it's for everyone but I'm a
proud strict mom taken down a few
notches proud of the daughters I raised
and proud of my relationship with them
what I want to do now is switch gears
and address some of uh the weaknesses
that I see in Western parenting first on
the point of
self-esteem Western parents spend a lot
of time worrying about this but I'm not
really sure they know how to instill it
I think we do our children a disservice
when we praise them when they know they
haven't put in their best effort or when
we give them trophies when they haven't
accomplished anything that doesn't give
them real Inner Strength real
self-esteem has to be earned by
overcoming a challenge or mastering
something jokes about a pluses and gold
medals aside for me in the end it's not
about grades or achievement it's about
believing in your child more than anyone
else not letting them give up even when
they want to and helping them see that
they are capable of more than they
think second on the point of choice and
freedom whereas I think Asian parenting
tends to give children too little choice
I think Western parents tend to give
children too much Choice particularly
when they're very young if you give a
six or seven-year-old uh the choice to
pursue their passions on any given day
that passion is going to be probably
playing video games and eating candy all
day very young children are not mature
enough to know what's best for them I
remember once Lulu came home from school
with a bad math test she was about 7
years old and she came home and
announced I hate math I'm bad at math
now I think a lot of Western parents I
know this because this is my husband uh
would say don't worry Lulu you don't
need to be good at math you could be
good at something else not everybody has
to be good at math I went the other way
I said no way how do you know you of
course you're good at math and I wrote
up all these practice tests um and we
drilled them I had a stop
every night for one week um it wasn't
guantan Bay it was just one
week and after that uh the next test one
week later she actually did very well on
her test and then she decided that she
quite liked math and today at 15 math is
her favorite subject one of the reasons
that my husband who was raised
completely differently supported my
strict parenting is because he was
actually somebody who wished his parents
had forced more things on him he he
remembers when he was about eight and
his mom gave him the choice do you want
to learn to play the violin or go play
with your friends go play with my
friends um he also wishes that somebody
had forced him to learn a second
language when we got married he got the
language tapes didn't work it's really
hard to learn Chinese at age
third I think that Western parenting or
at least the mommy Wars is often based
on false dichotomies there's a tendency
in these parenting yours to boil
everything down to Black or White do you
want success for your kids or happiness
do you want to be a strict parent or let
your kids have fun do you want them to
drill and work hard or do you want them
to be creative and I think these are
false choices and not helpful and I
think they tend to give parents the easy
way out take
happiness if I had a magic button and I
could choose either happiness for my
children or success I would choose
happiness in a second that's a
no-brainer I just think that it's more
complicated I do not believe that if you
say to your children do whatever you
want pursue your passions I love you
that that will necessarily lead to
happier adults and I don't even think it
necessarily leads to happier children in
all the Western Nations we have very
high rates of teenage depression teenage
alcohol and substance abuse and teenage
age pregnancy and in general I think
these are problems of too little
structure not too much and they do not
lead to happiness another false
dichotomy creativity or practice and
hard work obviously we want both
particularly in America I think there's
a tendency to romanticize creativity
just give your kid a saxophone an
amazing Jazz will pop
out especially areas with math like math
and music you need to have basic skills
first before you can come up with string
theory or the theory of relativity you
need to know how to multiply really well
before you can play an amazing Mozart
conero brilliantly and emotionally and
passionately you need to be able to play
in tune you need those basic foundations
first I want to wrap up uh by saying
that I didn't write this book to have
foreign policy
implications uh those are my two
previous book which nobody ever
read um but nevertheless like it or not
um child raring in fact is inextricably
linked to the future of Nations and I
have no doubt I've been thinking how
could this happen to me why I have no
doubt that at least part of the reason
for The Firestorm at least in the United
States is that my book accidentally
tapped into to two of America's deepest
anxieties fear of parenting and fear of
China
okay but China has but China you has
anxieties too you might be amused to
know that my book with no words changed
is being marketed in China in exactly
the opposite way in fact uh I'm a lawyer
when I first saw the cover of my book I
thought oh my God I need to bring a
lawsuit to uh bring an injunctive relief
because I looked at the cover and the
Chinese title of my book is Parenting by
a Yale law professor raising kids in
America and there's a picture of me in a
red white and blue flag and so I asked
my Chinese friends I said this is I
can't take this this is terrible but
talking to a lot of Chinese people they
explained to me and convince me that
it's actually not a bad title the reason
for that is because all of the things
that are so outraging the Western
audiences you know uh drilling math and
piano to um uh uh you know two hours a
day no playdates or sleepovers they
never even heard of these things um are
are not even controversial I mean that's
just not even considered
strict I think you'll be um so for them
it's the last part of the book you know
this see this woman learned to give her
kids more choice and more freedom and
things came out well so that's a how the
book is being pitched I'm sort of the
cuddly mom over there
um the uh done okay great let me just so
the key takeaway Point um am I done with
10 minutes or 12 oh 12 okay so let me
just uh the key point I want to make
here is that China is trying to learn
from the west and I think instead of
being complacent we should try to learn
from China too um to conclude then I
just want to ask everybody here tonight
to think back to your own parents or
grandparents or the generation that
survived wartime Europe
what do you think those parents were
like I bet they didn't sugarcoat or
spend their whole time arranging play
dates for them parenting was about
preparing kids for the future to ensure
that they would have a better life after
all the British education system was one
of the envies of the world and perhaps
it's time to reclaim those traditional
British values of discipline rigor hard
work and respect for excellence thank
you
thank you very much Amy that was
extremely amusing and did you notice she
reclaimed her
character um the first Speaker against
the motion is Justine Roberts um the ex-
banker who started a mother's website
mumsnet in her back room after her
babies were born and who now finds
herself one of the most famous and
influential women in Britain every
political leader quoted that website at
the last election and Justine's just
published um a new book of which he's
the co-author the mom's net rules which
is aimed at parents who would like to
navigate parenting without losing either
their cool or their sanity Justine thank
you well I should start by saying having
spent a futile 30 minutes trying to
prize my 5-year-old away from Angry
Birds this morning at and towards his
cornflakes that I am very very strongly
tempted to cross the floor and join
Amy's
team um but fortunately there are plenty
of other Western parents out there some
of you in the audience no doubt uh who
are far better role models than me and I
will speak I hope on your behalf um so
yes if we judge um ourselves by the
number of musical prudes we produce and
the number of mass wizzes
Asian parents are beating us hands down
there's no doubt about it and I agree
with Amy who does not regret giving not
practicing their instrument more who
amongst us wishes perhaps they hadn't
given up uh at the first chance and who
doesn't think that they might have got
better grades if the either their
teachers or their parents had pushed
them a bit more but we know in our bones
that there is more to life than
agres uh and most of us I think would
count a happy pre- childhood as being
one of the best gifts gifts we could
bestow on our children and on that we're
not doing too badly now a survey of
British teens recently found that seven
out of 10 were very
satisfied very satisfied how many teens
do you know who are very satisfied about
anything they were very satisfied about
their lives in contrast South Korea has
the highest rate of teen depression in
the oecd and the biggest killer of 17 to
2 four-year-olds in South Korea which I
have to say are are kind of the most
tigerish of all the tiger Nations as far
as parenting is concerned is
suicide you know it's no joke this
onethird of CH Chinese primary school
children suffer from psychological ill
health Accord according to a recent
survey and that's caused they say by
classroom pressure and parental uh
parental stress um so it must be said
you know I personally might swap a
little bit of psychological ill health
for a few fewer Renditions of Chopsticks
paid ever more badly but you know we're
relatively speaking I don't think we're
doing that
badly quite apart from being a good
parent you know um you know quite a
large part of it I agree with Amy is
preparing our children for the future
and some of that does involve learning
skills yes the mass of music but only
some of it imag imagination creativity
crital critical thinking and social
skills are important and evidence shows
that rote learning really does um yes it
results in proficiency but it doesn't do
much for
creativity uh a recent survey of 29
countries that that found the Chinese
came first in terms of their calculation
skills but they came last for
imagination the Chinese way um is one of
obsessing about perfection in Amy's book
she talks about only top of the class is
acceptable gold medal is the only medal
I will accept nothing but a grades uh
but if you chase Perfection the chances
are you're going to be quite risk averse
um if all that matters in life is
scoring top marks when will you ever
take a chance now this Tory government
is very fond of telling us that the only
way we will get out of our current
economic meire is VI Entre entrepreneurs
entrepreneurs will help us escape and
entrepreneurs are Risk Takers we need
Risk Takers we need innovators and if
you look at this country three of our
most famous businessman entrepreneurs uh
Richard Branson Alan sugar Simon Cal
barely got a GCS between
them and who who wouldn't want to
produce Simon Cal I mean he's he's very
nice to his mom I'm
told it's silly to suggest that we're
perfect in the west I wouldn't pretend
that for a second yes we struggle to get
our kids off Facebook off Angry Birds
and onto the piano stool and some of us
quite frankly hanker after the old days
where we could say you do it because I
told you say um but the answer is not
authoritarian parenting it's not right
to control through shame which is some
of the approach that Amy advocates in
her book
instead what the moms net has would
suggest in the collective wisdom of the
mumsnet rules is an approach of
authoritative parenting this does
emphasize high standards we agree you
should have man manners you should be
diligent you should even ask your
children to do some chores around the
house and start them early but it's
accompanied by parental warmth and yes
I'm afraid it's a accompanied by a
commitment to reasoning unless of course
they're arguing for a guinea pig in
which case no amount of reasoning should
Prevail frankly tiger parenting is just
not viable in our modern democratic
individualistic Society believe me I've
tried it now and then and invariably I
get confronted with children who say
they're about to call the Social
Services uh at the same time giving an
impassioned speech about the rights of
man but on balance wouldn't you rather
that wouldn't you rather have children
with a strong sense of themselves with
confidence uh in their own work Earth I
know I would even if sometimes I wish
they would practice the piano more thank
you very
[Applause]
much thank you Justine the second
speaker for the motion is someone who
has never been surprised when his views
have caused controversy Theodore Dal
rmle is the pseudonym of Anthony Daniels
and he's a doctor who for 15 years wrote
wiy Savage and often deeply depressing
accounts of the lives of his
underprivileged patients in the pages of
The Spectator and his despare about the
gulf which he clearly saw
between the values that he was brought
up with and those which he thought he
saw being espoused in the people around
him was absolutely evident but equally
evident and for some readers as a very
uncomfortable J position was the
contempt in which it was felt he held
some of those people Theodor is the
author of spoiled the toxic Cult of
[Applause]
sentimentality well thank you Madame
chairman ladies and gentlemen um I first
realized that there was something wrong
with the way uh we bring up our children
of course other than my own
childhood um and I must here tell you
about a friend of mine who a Russian who
went to live in in America and he at his
parties at parties he always introduced
himself and said uh hello I'm such and
such I hate my parents don't you and he
never found anybody who didn't hate
their
parents uh but I first realized that
there was something wrong when a friend
of mine who was working in Pediatrics
told me that a mother had come to him
asking uh for his help Dr she said uh
can't you do something about Johnny he's
terrible he smashes things he won't do
what he's told and you should hear his
language well I had a a not dissimilar
experience shortly afterwards a patient
came to me she had a son with her who
just had his uh third birthday and there
wasn't anyone who could look after him
at that moment so she had to bring him
into my room and the child was not
surprisingly restless and started to
pick up things from the uh from the
desk and she said put that down he put
it down picked up something else she put
that
down and uh he put it down and then
finally he picked up the telephone and
she said put that down and he looked at
her bear in mind he's just had his third
birthday he turned to her and with sheer
malignity in his eyes said well
you now of course these are mere
anecdotes uh but if you listen to the
children coming out of the school in the
little market town in which I live when
I'm in England uh which is prosperous
and without the Great RIS social
problems uh you can hear the same kind
of
thing and what is symptomatic is that uh
when children are on the street in any
numbers when they come out of school uh
adults shrink away half in fear and half
in disgust and this is not imaginary I
would take you and show
you and incidentally I was uh just lying
down in my bedroom here in South kington
and I heard the children coming out and
the average British child it seems to me
cannot go further than about 10 yards
without an
exploitive it's kind of rocket fuel for
him and the and I also saw in a little
Supermarket because I'd forgotten to buy
some razors bring some razors uh a
French mother obviously very well off
actually fighting with her child in the
in the
supermarket and the security person in
this uh uh Supermarket told me that this
was by no means
uncommon now it's obviously not true
that no parents bring up their children
well in the west and obviously many do
so I'm asking you to consider this
motion not statically but dynamically in
terms of Trends rather than the current
state and I shall also refer to Britain
both because I know it best and because
Britain is in the Forefront or Vanguard
of almost anything that is
undesirable and uh unfortunately other
countries uh tend to move in our
Direction rather than the other
way well consider this what what does it
mean that more than a third of children
in this country never eat a meal at a
table with another member of their
family or perhaps I should say household
I used to go into houses when I was
practicing as a doctor and there were
many such houses in which Not only was
there no cooking apparatus unless you
count microwave oven's cooking apparatus
but there was no single piece of
furniture at which people could have
eaten
together and that's over a third of
children in this country and this is not
a small matter because of course eating
together is one of the most Elementary
and I think important manners of
socialization of learning to control
one's appetite and behavior for the sake
of others and it's not available to a
very considerable proportion of the
population uh of children in this
country it's hardly surprising then that
so many of them are
fat and this obesity is a manifestation
simultaneously of overindulgence and
neglect you could say overindulgence as
neglect or neglect as
overindulgence overindulgence because no
attempt is made to reign in their
appetites and neglect because such
riging in is very difficult it's painful
it requires training and
discipline and it's usually on the part
of the mother but also on the part of
the
Father Again children in Britain are by
the end of their childhood nearly twice
as likely to have a television in their
bedroom as a father living at
home is this not also a sign of
indulgence and neglect of course not
every such um upbringing ends in
disaster either social or psychological
or economic or anything like that
because human beings are very resilient
uh creatures but this is surely far from
good let alone
optimal
if you look around many perhaps most of
our schools you will find the
surroundings astonishingly
littered the reason that no one in this
room
litters is not because each time he or
she has a piece of potential litter in
his or her possession uh and and he
makes a decision not to litter by means
of a deduction from a cartisian first
principle which is
indubitable it is because his mommy told
him or her not got to and instilled it
into him or her well wherever you go in
this country as it happens I've just
written a book about this uh there is um
there is uh litter and if you want to
see the nplus ultra of it I recommend
the A14 between the m6 and
Huntington it's truly astonishing each
piece of litter and there are millions
of them is a kind of material trait
place of deficient
socialization I am amused but also
despairing when I see the children in my
town approach a litter bin with a piece
of litter and then as if they knew that
litter bins had something to do with
litter but they couldn't quite work out
what it was they drop it not in it but
by
it in other words civilized or Civic
conduct in this country is a kind of
faint memory it's a bit it's a bit like
what somebody one of my patients said
when I asked him who Shakespeare was he
said it rings a
bell well I'll I'll be very brief
I'll uh when someone in my town
complained of uh the litter around the
school the school instit Ed litter
studies if we take education in this
country we spend £60,000 per head on
education uh on compulsory education or
I should say attendance at school and
yet 25% about
25% of our children turn out illiterate
and enumerate or barely literate and
barely enumerate there is no protest
about this whatsoever and if a teacher
should should draw attention and no
doubt he uses very bad methods in
teaching but nevertheless if he draws
attention to some deficiency in school
he is more likely to be attacked by the
parents than the parents are are likely
to try and do anything about the child
and in this country recent survey showed
that 10% of Headmasters has have been
physically attacked in the last year uh
by uh by parents or what are known as
car carers of
children if you take again the the lack
of protest about this terrible
deficiency it is not that mothers do not
protest in this country if you see a
pedophile being brought to court there
are often large numbers of of mothers
with terrified children in toe screaming
for the death of the
pedophile but if you look at the the
story of the so murderer what it
revealed what was interesting about that
was what it revealed about the
murderers relations with many children
before and the complicity of parents in
what he had done in for example a TW the
mother of a 12-year-old refused to
cooperate with the police uh in
investigating illegal sexual relations
with so ladies and gentlemen to conclude
I will say taken in the round there is
plenty of reason to support this
evidence if you do not take it too
literal mindedly thank
you thank you Theodor and the final
speaker against the motion is Frank
fured who is the provocative professor
of Sociology at the University of Kent
and Frank is a slightly unusual academic
in that he's actively interested in
taking academic debates and bringing
them out into the public Arena he's
particularly interested in the whole
questions of authority and parenting and
how he managed the relationships between
children and adults in a suspicious
Society he's the author of 13 books
including paranoid parenting Frank thank
you very much
[Applause]
Jenny good evening everybody I I don't
know if you noticed but whenever it
comes to discussion on parenting
everybody feels that they got a warrant
to take their own personal story and to
recast it as a grand
philosophy and on no other issues are we
allowed to communicate such prejudices
and such stereotypes as we do in
relation to Parenting so Theodore
happened to hear a couple of children
swearing and it's concluded that has
never happened before in British Society
you know children of my generation would
never use a four-letter word that was
Unthinkable uh whereas now what we have
is this epidemic this pathology of
children going around and swearing and
and and because of that uh sort of
obviously British parents are not doing
their bit Amy on the other hand
concludes that in Western societies
children have too much choice in fact
they have so much choice in Britain that
middle class children in London have
literally their entire life organized
for them by their parents from the
moment they got up in the morning for
the first set of activities as they kind
of transfer around by their parents from
this activity to the next
literally they got no free time to be
children and to relax the idea that
somehow we live in a world where
children have these incredible choices
you know so parents are laidback chilled
out just get on with it is a myth that
bears literally no relationship to
reality and I think it's important to
realize that uh you know when we're
talking about Western parenting you know
uh what we are really talking about is
intensive parenting Western parenting is
phenomenally intensive parents spend far
more time with their children today than
they did in any other Generations a a
working mother in the 21st century in
Britain spends about 2 three hours more
a day looking after her children that a
mother who stayed at home in the 1970s
that's how intensive it really is and I
think what's very interesting is that
all these so-called Asian attributes
that are brought out in am's books are
not Asian at all I mean anybody body
that's been been to New York Westchester
County been to Cambridge Massachusetts
will recognize those characteristics
straight away just to give you an
example of how this works uh the other
day A friend of mine who lives in New
York uh told me a story about how her
four-year-old child has been on this
waiting list for this high-powered
preschool Nursery a waiting list and and
she's been on us for months and months
and months and she really was at a loss
to know how she could you know sort of
train her child to get into a nursery so
she can play with toys and and
develop and at first I thought she was
exaggerating the way most parents do so
I went online and I discovered this uh
online service which is called how to
Ace at a preschool interview this is in
in New York these are not CH this is not
an online service for Chinese people or
for Cambodian refugees this is address
towards
westerners it this what they say
education nowadays starts even before
kindergarten like age three
months the best and the most elite
preschools don't just have expensive T
tuition they have long waiting lists of
eager parents who would love to send
their children there in a heartbeat if
you're lucky enough to have a preschool
call you and your child for an interview
you should do everything in your power
to give the best possible
impression now that kind of intensive
High powerered
parenting would be familiar to anybody
that lives in Northern L North London as
it would be in most middle class
neighborhoods throughout the country in
in in London as far as I can tell there
seem to be more tutors of young children
than rats these days literally literally
everybody I
know has got a has got a Tor working for
them so that's on the on this kind of
stereotype that we're very laid-back and
relaxed we care about self-esteem we
don't you know we don't let you know we
kind of allow children to make too much
choices and then the other side of the
stereotype is that in China or in Asia
parents are really hardass I mean they
really they they would never dream of
spoiling a child right the fact that
there are these little Emperors in
China and that there's been a a
protracted debate in China about how
children are spoiled by their parents a
debate that's been going on for a very
very long time um it just happens to be
an awkward fact and if you happen to
have gone to Shanghai or if you go to
Beijing you'll find that the equivalent
of the Westchester mummies and the
Islington daddies in China have entire
exactly the same parenting style maybe
they say it in the Chinese language they
not than English as they do here so it
seems to me that what we're discussing
at the moment are essentially two middle
class approaches towards parenting
rather than anything that is culturally
different from one another so it's very
easy to get confused in the debate my
argument is simple and straightforward
Western parents are actually quite good
at parenting it's not rocket science you
don't need a pH in development
psychology to be a good mom or or a good
dad there's no problem with Western
parents the real problem is that we do
everything possible to make it very
difficult for parents to have confidence
in making judgment calls we make it very
very difficult for parents to live the
life of being a good parents because all
of their intuition all of their all of
their way approaches towards life is
continually
undermined so what are the problems with
with with with problems that we Face the
first problem that we face in the west
and Western culture is that we devalue
parental competence time and time again
we continually pathologize what parents
do politicians of all political parties
seem to dine out on on on lecturing
parents about their failures and I I can
still see the moment I think it was
either David Cameron but it could have
been Gordon Brown because on this day at
one you know they are totally together
on this particular kind of issue I
remember that typical sort of
presidential lecture where you get that
kind of look on their that pain look on
their face they that passionate care
that really pain look as they say you
know you know Jim this is on the Today
program parenting is probably the most
difficult job in the
world right and everybody gives them a
standing ofation because we you know
it's such an obvious thing parenting is
the most difficult job in the world
actually it
isn't I tell you if you know being a
nuclear physicist is a little bit more
difficult it's a little bit more
difficult than being a parent being a
you know sort of a like a Formula One
driver on balance is a bit more
complex than changing the Naes of your
son right but the very idea that we say
parenting is the most difficult job in
the world which sounds really good it's
meant to say meant to communicate the
idea that that I feel for you you know I
take this very seriously is actually
another way of saying that you mom over
there and you dad over there are
unlikely to be up to this very difficult
job right you Mom and you dad need a
phenomenal amount of parenting advice
you need a a policy of experts to come
in and hold your hands and give you what
what Cameron and bran always call
support right so it seems to me that
what we have under these circumstances
are these very helpful reminders that
tell us how difficult parenting is which
then makes parents very insecure which
then leads to what I think is the the
real problem is that when there are so
much pressure on parents to do this very
difficult job what they invariably do is
begin to live their life through their
children and as you live your life to
your children you begin to lose sight of
just what it is that you ought to be
doing and because you live your life to
your child your parenting style becomes
synonymous with your
identity and I think that's a really sad
tragic thing about the world that we
live in we forget about the real job of
child rearing and we become much more
concerned about parenting as a cultural
accomplishment of identity construction
and the reason why we have these debates
and we have debates around dinner tables
all the time is because these days when
your identity is apparent is so much
part of who you are you cannot simply
say well Amy brings her child up this
way that's cool I don't like it but
that's her business right just brings up
her kid that way yeah well you know bit
slack not what I would do but but fine
you know
instead of saying I'm just leaving it at
that we do it differently because maybe
our children are different our
circumstances are different we need to
make a political issue out of who we are
as parents and the more we make a
political issue out of who we are as
parents the more we take our eyes of the
real job which is just looking after our
kids in the best way that we can and I
think that on a good day Western parents
do that really really well and the
problem is not the fact that Western
parents cannot bring up their kids the
real problem is that because of all
these pressures that I've
described Western parents have lost the
capacity to chill out relax and get a
life thank
you
thank you Frank well from the whoops of
Applause that greeted that last
contribution you might be unsurprised to
know that in the prevote the the number
of people voting for the motion was 149
the number against was
325 but the don't NOS amount to 194 so
there are an awful lot of people to be
swayed over the next 25 minutes um I'd
like to start by um dimming the light
slightly so that I could see the
audience because now it's time for
questions but at the moment the lights
are so bright that I can't quite make
anybody out um there are a couple of
ushers who have got microphones um and
we're going to take questions in threes
and it would be great if you could just
say briefly who you were but apart from
that please keep your questions very
brief and to the point and don't make
statements because I'll just have to
move on um could we start if anyone
who'd like to speak raising their
hands no one's got anything to
contribute um somebody right at the back
there
hello um my name's J I'm parent a seveny
old and I'm just wanted to BR studies um
I just wanted to ask um Justine a
question actually because I do think
that there is um a sort of tendency for
us to sort to say well we don't want to
impose too much on our children and I
think we do it in education as well um
do you think that there's a tendency
nowadays to um make children make
decisions work out their own risks and
all this kind of thing and actually what
we're doing is we're creating U we're
sort of saying well we can't do it
ourselves so we'll let the children do
it and um we're creating a nation of
warriors in our own children thank you
very much Josephine is there another
hand gentleman here in the
middle and another one after that thank
you this question is for any yeah I had
a tiger mom and I was actually wondering
um looking back how would you recommend
um encouraging your children to follow
their passions but still um I guess
having that rigorous high level
achieving type of an attitude thank you
and young boy over here I just wanted to
ask do you think that achieving
academically is as um good as achieving
like socially is that a question for
anyone in particular
no thank you very much Amy do you want
to start to start out what would be the
new revised tiger
mothering um well in the end I actually
do think that uh having your kids follow
their passions is the most important
thing um you know I think that uh I
guess where I would differ with a lot of
Western parents is I don't always assume
especially when kids are little that
they know exactly what that passion is
going to be um you know I know if you
ask my uh children my girls you know
their best all of their friends at
around age 12 they all want to be
Hollywood film producers and rock stars
and I wouldn't be against that I think
those are actually great passions but
they're they're those are hard to
achieve too you know so um but to answer
your question I you know I don't I'm
still struggling with this myself um
Lulu wanted to play tennis instead of
violin and it really broke my heart
because she was a beautiful and very
emotional violin player and all I can
say is maybe it's about instilling those
early skills uh at a young age so that
they kind of have rigor and focus and
then letting them just kind of out to uh
pursue to make their own choices later
um a nice compliment I got from her
coach was uh you know that you know your
kid has a great work ethic she never
blames anybody she really just keeps at
it she doesn't give up so I was thinking
wow maybe you know Chinese parenting did
work with Lulu afterall and I started
getting all excited I started you know
like making calls and uh she said lay
off mommy you know I don't need you um
uh this is my thing so so I'm still
looking for that right balance Amy just
to pick up that do you think that
achieving academically is as important
more important than achieving socially
you kept your children away from play
dates and so on for much many of their
years did that matter I I actually think
that
socialization uh is extremely important
and I think that in China this is a real
problem or I've seen kids that look like
their parents agree with Frank they're
just hovering over them they can't do
anything um I don't tend to think that
this is the main problem we have in the
west so my you know I think we've overe
exaggerated the need to kind of sculpt
uh you know how much playtime when I was
little we just played outside and the
neighbors uh you know and the states
there's a lot of play time at school and
my kids actually did have plenty of play
dates and playground things before you
know when they were very little it's
only between the ages of eight and 14
which is a lot of years that I would say
they had far few sleepovers and
playdates they had tons of friends tons
of friends at school you know these
camps these music camps these Sports
things um so I think socialization I
actually agree that it's equally
important I've seen it um but uh but I
think maybe again it's Asia and the West
have gone too far in opposite extremes
that you know Asia might have to worry
about this can we produce leaders that
can function and and be you know be
funny and humorous and have initiative
but I'm I'm just think that that's not
our main weakness that uh we don't have
enough play
dates Frank you want just come in quick
yeah uh I think that uh it's not right
to to talk about socialization and
education academic education in the same
bread for a very simple reason that
parents are the worst teachers for their
children I mean I don't know if ever any
of you ever ski and and and and and and
watched parents trying to teach their
kids how to ski and they're so
emotionally involved in the whole
process that they they can they just
kind of lose control over the whole
thing because they there's too much
involved and similarly parents who do a
lot of homework with their kids end up
losing sight of their own needs from
that of the child and that's why I would
argue that yeah academic stuff is
important but leave that to teachers and
to schools and to universities on the
other hand parents are
indispensable for giving kids very clear
cues and signals about how to make their
way in the world and what parents be
very good at is socializing children to
communicate values to them to show them
how you engage in awkward situations and
I think uh to that extent we should be
very very clear that parenting really
works well when it's discreet when it's
about child rearing the more we load on
to Parenting you know my parents become
therapists and teachers and philosophers
and all the rest of that mentors the
more parenting becomes denuded of any
real content and I think that's the best
way of of seeing the two Justine what do
you think about that and what do you
think about the idea that we're loading
too many choices onto
children um I think you know I I hate to
disagree with my own side oh no pre
country but I would just say that I
think it's impossible not to be a mentor
as a parent and in some way to be a
therapist I mean you know it's you who's
going to be there at 11:30 of night when
they're sort of worried about their
boyfriend or whatever but that's a only
a slight disagreement Frank but broadly
we are a team um on the on the sort of
choice question um I think actually
choice on on the whole empowers a child
I think if you're talking about causing
angst and worry uh you know choosing
your child's GS gcses or making them do
physics when they'd rather do art that
probably causes a lot more angst um but
I do think there is a limit to choice
and I kind of agree I think with the
sense I get from Amy that you know we
can give our choices uh our our young
kids too much Choice um I know this from
personal experience when my 5-year-old
son chose to go to school in a gypsy
skirt um and um he never did again after
that horrible day but I possibly
shouldn't have allowed that to happen
and certainly most of the other parents
at the school thought I'd made a
terrible Choice there
myself thank you can we take another
round of questions if there's anyone on
the balcony oh yes I can see someone
right there's a static microphone there
would you like to come forward to it and
then um I can't sorry I can't quite see
you but do come line up behind the
speaker um and you there go ahead hi
Elizabeth forter House really just
addressing the panel I've just heard
talk of over involved under involved
parents and really I don't know if
anyone could inform me with regards to
mental ill health in children
statistically West versus East that's it
thank
you I have a more practical question I
have two kids one five and 17 and I
would bring in a new sort of uh uh idea
to the whole debate ambition because I
want my children to be the best but I
don't want them to be the best because
they afraid of me or because I was up
until midnight with them but uh the
question would be can you teach ambition
and if you can how how do you make
children to be ambitious so that they
strive for the best because of their own
good not because of an external pressure
wow effortless achieving ambition H
that's a Holy Grail I look forward to
the
answers hi I'm Viv grop um I'm a writer
and mother of three children which I've
recently discovered is an answer to the
question how many children is twoo many
children bit late to find that out um I
wanted to pick up on what Theodore dmle
said um about the man who asked everyone
um I I hate my parents don't you too
isn't this whole debate really about our
greatest fear which is excepting the
inevitable that our children will hate
us thank you very
much
um the I think I'm going to start with
you as a doctor want therefore to know
about statistics on mental health and
perhaps answers to all the rest too I
don't know well I I I don't actually
know the statistics about this and in
any case child cchi is such a woolly
subject that I I wouldn't put much trust
them all I can say is that in France
they have the highest consumption of um
uh of psychotropic medicine in the world
by quite a long way um as far as uh
parents um inevitably being hated by uh
by their uh children I thought I was
pessimistic but
um I yield that you yield to this I
yield to that kind of pessimism
um so um and how how do you instill some
an effortless sense of ambition well I
don't I don't that's a very diffic
difficult question because I don't think
it's merely a question of what adults uh
parents do it it's uh it's much more uh
socially um U socially constructed than
that and that that uh if you live in in
a large in large parts of Britain for
example there is no ambition other than
to be a footballer or a um or to be a
pop star and when they talk about talent
that is what that is what they mean by
talent and so I think that it would be
very difficult for parents in those
circumstances too to so I I think that
is a very difficult Amy do you have some
quick response to that one yeah I have
us very um on the our children will
inevitably hate us uh I just have such a
different uh World viiew um uh you know
maybe it's just a falling into Frank's
trap my own it's just one case of one
but um but you know I absolutely adore
my parents and my father's actually here
this evening and we my kids absolutely
love my parents and we really do
vacation together I'm literally every
vacation we take we include my parents
so uh I just don't have such a bleak
view on the ambition question I guess
myself I I wouldn't necessarily want to
instill just blind ambition in my
children uh despite my uh reputation um
but uh for me I think it's an
interesting question which is how do you
instill uh self motivation and I think
it's absolutely true uh on the chill out
point that I think some people are going
to be inherently selfmotivated my
husband had the lack as parents nothing
and very very just some people are sort
of driven for one reason or the other um
but have having said that I do think
that parents can play a role I sort of
see it more as um it being inspiring
there have been so many times both my
girls have come and said I'm bad at this
whether it's in music or school and just
being blah I hate this and I think it's
a a it's too romantic to assume that
everybody is either self-motivated and
driven or not again that's a little bit
a bleak view I think I'm actually an
optimist I feel like when you get good
at things when you work at things you
often discover oh my God I it's this is
more fun than I thought so that's where
I see uh parenting feeding into the
motivation issue Frank can I just ask
you as a sociologist there's um quite a
lot of evidence um that it's the peer
group that affects children and their
values quite a lot more than parenting
is that something you could in answer
that question up there how do you
instill ambition yeah I I think that uh
that's really important that quite often
it's the children your son or daughter
hangs out with that becomes really
critical because if you can create the
right Dynamic for example if you're I've
got a 15-year-old boy and it just so
happens that although I'm a a slothful
slack F his friends are all 13 books can
I remind you
are his friends are all into reading and
therefore it's really cool to read books
and it's really you know interesting to
you know for them to be academically
involved and it's to do with the fact
that that peer group is for some reason
I don't understand why has moved in that
trajectory
and it seems to me that peer pressure is
really a very creative very constructive
dynamic in a children's experience
irreplaceable in many ways but there's
one thing that parents can do um and and
and seems to work not so much instill
ambition but to continually send out the
signal of raising
expectations I think that when children
learn from a very early age on that a
lot of that everything is possible for
them that we think that there are no
limits that the bar is is set fairly
high that even if they lack motivation
themselves even if they're not that
driven nevertheless you know they will
play the role and I think that's that's
an important thing that we've learned
and one thing that I I learned when I
was doing my interviews is after a while
you could pretty much tell which
children would do well in school
compared to other children in the same
socioeconomic
circumstances and the and the single
most important variable wasn't parenting
skills it wasn't the fact that mom stood
on her head and kind of sped out 5 P
pieces it was the fact that uh there's a
very clear expectation uh that anything
is possible and I think that was the key
element and that's something that
teachers have learned and other people
have learned as being quite important
it's it's the mure we create for our
kids rather than what we actually do
that's important thank you
Justine I agree with all that I think
those questions have brought up um dare
I say two of the sort of vulnerable
spots of of the western parent uh and
one is our tendency in the past to um
indulge in sort of pointless praise uh
you know the scribble come someone
scribbled a drawing and you say that's
marvelous darling I'll put it on the
fridge um which has created a sort of
Praise junky culture and it sort of
makes renders all effort pointless and
all achievement redundant um so I think
we are a bit vulnerable to that and we
do say in our book judicious praise is
what you should be aiming for if you
want your child to really value um what
they do and the other thing is I think
we are all a little bit guilty of
wanting our kids to be our best friends
and therefore um perhaps thinking that
we're not the boss in the house and we
can't make the rules and that then gets
you into situations where you can't
remove them from Club Penguin um so so I
do think you know they're very good
questions and I think we have to guard
very carefully against those two
practices uh in our Western parenting
world thank you can we take some more
questions um lady here in the stripe
jumper um lady in the front row and
person right at the back
yes do start okay this question is for
Amy um I was wondering if you could
comment on the uh crazy us College
admissions
process uh could you be a little bit
more specific I mean that could be a
really long
lecture so uh you know schools publish
data about how test scores are getting
higher and higher which uh you could
conclude would mean that applicants are
more and more talented but in my opinion
it's the same baguer kids running faster
and faster to stay in the same place the
nature of the US rat race thank you yes
lady in
front hello Yan peel just wanted to ask
the speakers how they would respond to
the statement which may be a coroller of
questions we've heard or of the motion
itself uh that Western children don't
know how to respect their
parents thank you and lady at the
back yes i' like to ask Amy a question
uh rosn Portman from family links and we
deliver a nuturing program through uh
trained facilitators around the UK and
the outcome from our groups is that
parent say for the first time they can
enjoy being parents because they learned
to set boundaries and they learn to be
in charge of their children I was
wondering Amy if parenting education has
crept into China and if um Chinese
parents would welcome an
opportunity thank you um Amy do you want
to start with that question is there too
much pressure in the college Rat Race
now um well first of all I just have to
unlike a couple of my co-panelists I
really you know did just write WR a
memoir so I am not a child psychologist
or an education expert or a sociologist
um I have tons of expertise uh on those
other two books I mentioned U uh so uh
but just all I can talk about is with
that is that I completely agree that the
college admissions process is absurd I
mean I just think it's at so many
different levels um and I don't even
know where to begin um I feel like
something is broke with the system there
there a movie a film documentary film
called race to nowhere in the states
where it shows that uh teenagers in the
United States are so stressed out about
this that they're uh you know on
medication and they get ulcers and they
have to cheat and I feel what I really
feel about this is that there's um a
little bit of a schizophrenia among
Western parenting which is we we're very
ambivalent about it in the west so from
ages zero to about 14 or 15 you want to
tell your children we don't care about
grades don't focus on those things no
pressure pursue your passions you know
we're not going to be hierarchical and
authoritative and then my daughter
Sophia says around sophomore year in
high schools everywhere suddenly you
meet the college counselor and he hands
to you all these stats and these are all
the numbers that you need the GPA and
the SAT scores and by the way here are
all the colleges that you already can't
get into you know and then no wonder at
that point these teenagers are
scrambling they they're stressed out
they they don't have the work skills to
so I could go on and on about that but I
really do think that there's a a real a
problem that is not productive there and
I guess the other question was the um
Chinese do they need parenting education
uh
I I do think that the Chinese do um they
need a lot of things um and I I again
I'm not an expert um for me it's more
interesting how much this anxiety about
parenting has to do I think with
privilege and uh you know if you're
somebody starving you know you're in the
uh like my own parents or you know the
Great Depression or if you come over as
an immigrant you have no money um you
just don't have time to to look for
parenting guides and to worry about that
you know it's just all about survival so
I think that China is much more
interesting in parenting now partly
because of increased affluence and they
in a way have the luxury to worry about
which method is best and I think what
they are trying to do is exactly this is
the flip side of Justine is saying you
know I think they do need to learn more
in some ways uh they probably do need
counseling they don't have a strong
child psychology uh a tradition there
how to communicate love you know how to
listen to Children better I mean there
are a lot of scarred kids from uh from
too much strictness so um but again I
don't want to speak because I don't have
any empirical evidence about that Frank
um a quick answer do you Western
children have insufficient respect for
their
parents I think they do I I think they
usually the the respect that uh parents
get from their children is proportional
to the extent to which they deserve it
and and it's and it and it seems to me
that respect is something you earn you
don't get as an automatic right and
that's one of the dynamic aspects of a
good child parent
relationship thank you Justine you want
to come back on that yep no I agree with
that I think you know much as we would
love to uh Retreat into Victorian times
where children were not were seen and
not heard or you know perhaps our own
generation where we thought um you know
we were often told because I said so go
to your room I think we have entered the
age of reasoning and but that good the
flip side of that is your kids will
genuinely respect you not just because
that's the way they had to play behave
when they came out of the womb so uh I
think uh if if you can bear to reason
and fight the argument and uh give them
that time then ultimately they're more
likely to respect the outcome thank you
you um Anthony you wanted to come return
to some earlier Point yes just a little
thing about uh mental health um we in
Britain or adolescents and young uh
people lead the world in taking
overdoses um not in suicide I don't know
whether this is a reflection of the
general level of competence
but pretty strong statistic that one
however we are far in advance uh and I
personally examine 15,000 about 15,000
people who had who had done it is that
children or sorry is that children uh
had less Adolescence in young adults yes
recently children um I think we've got
time I'm afraid for one more random
question um the gentleman there with a
gray
hair thank you Christopher Martin I am I
am gray-haired I'm about 50 years older
than anybody else here tonight I think
um I was for 20 years a Headmaster of um
a number of schools um and was at one
point responsible for 1,200 young
adolescents all swimming energetically
in the hormonal cauldron um my question
is for Frank and Justine do you feel it
significant that in all that time I
never once encountered a parent who
didn't agree wholeheartedly in theory
initially with the school's disciplinary
framework as outlined to them but in
very many cases almost half I would
think um uh objected violently and
sometimes energetically when the the
disciplinary framework was applied to
them or their children
personally thank you very much and a
question up there yeah hiard I've got
four children and if Viv thinks that's
uh three is one too many let me tell you
that four is an awful lot um this is
really a question to Anthony who hasn't
picked up on the fact that that the fact
that British parents turn into tiger
parents largely because the school
situation here is so terribly skewed and
if you can't afford to get your child
into a private school let me tell you
you will become a tiger parent desperate
to get your child into a state selective
school or a half decent School you will
be there with the tutors with the cumon
with the this and that with the violin
and all that kind of stuff because if
your child isn't in that school the wish
for ambition as the other lady pointed
out the wish for social success the peer
group pressure all of that you can
forget it because you won't get it in
the other sort of schools that your
child will end up going
to thank you okay last
one hello um I'm Goda I'm a writer and a
mother for a little six-year-old girl
and my question is how do we balance
parenting skills for the current state
of Youth and the feature of future of
our Nations due to underachieving
children with no pressure parenting
theories underpaid teachers and scheme
aing councils who always trim down money
from the school's piggy bank so how do
you suggest you know doing parenting and
balancing things out without being a
tiger bom thank you thank you well
that's one that's one enormous topic for
a final round um I'm going to have to
ask um the panel to um respond to those
very quickly indeed um British parents
turning into tiger parents I think
Justine I think you could answer that
one as well as Anthony well I have to I
have enormous sympathy with the school's
argument I mean I think um there is um
there is that moment when and we
discussed it here tonight that peer
group is so important and you you look
at the local um State secondary and and
they're essentially carrying knives and
and you know it's Gangland and you do
realize at that point you probably do
have to be
a little bit more tigerish than you'd
wished um so I'm totally on board with
that and I think it's a shame and
obviously it's a wider social issue uh
and to the lovely Headmaster who um who
talked about um parents in his school
well you know parental bias is never
going to go away I'm afraid uh we're all
shortsighted when it comes to our
children and I'm just going to ask you
to address the tiger parents because I
think we'll take that wider issue and
hope that you you take it in your um
concluding remarks the four of you uh
yes I I mean the sit the educational
situation in this country is uh
disgraceful and it isn't a question of
money because we now spend four times as
much behead as we did in 1950 in real
terms uh but our rate of illiteracy is
if if anything higher than it was then
and I don't think money can I don't
think money can explain that I worked in
an area where I noticed a very big
difference between the children of
Indian immigrants and uh White uh
children and and also West Indian
children of West Indian and there was
this huge difference so that even where
the schools were very bad there was a
difference in the results because of the
uh wishes of the parents so I think what
we can see is that this this terrible
peer pressure also comes from the
culture that the parents themselves have
and I don't if I might say I don't think
it's true that uh that parents at one
time would have responded to the
headmaster's strictures in the way that
they now do I think that has
changed thank you very much um I hope
that the panel will be able to address
that question of um what do we do about
the general underachieving level of
British education in in the face of cuts
within their twom minute final speeches
because what's going to happen now is
that the ushers are coming around with
the ballot boxes for the final vote can
I just remind you against you either
drop in for or against or if you're
still in doubt drop your entire ticket
into the box
um and we're just going to start now
with the concluding speeches and the
first person speak is going to be frank
so can you whis can you keep your
whispering to your neighbors until 10
minutes time please go there yes
Frank could you all just be quiet please
while we listen o I want some
respect right I I just want to end with
the uh on the question that was read by
the Headmaster which is this the reason
why parents have become so uh sort of uh
promiscuous in tolerating bad behavior
by the children in school and the reason
why they don't back up teachers is
because there's been a lot of pressure
on parents to assume the burden of their
children's education
you know my parents never did homework
with me and if my parents had done some
homework with me that would that used to
be called cheating today it's seen as a
sign of responsibility responsible
parents do homework with their children
you know when little Mary gets her grade
then it's not just simply Mary who's
being examined her parent is being
examined and if she does well that
reflects on the parent she does poorly
then it's a condemnation of that parent
so it's not surprising that parents have
become Advocates of their child and have
lost the capacity to distance themselves
from the real objective needs of both
the school and of the child which really
brings me to the central problem that
we're confronted with Asia and Europe
and the problem is is that because of
all these pressures that we've been
discussing parents and adults in general
live so much of their life through their
child they recycle so much of their
emotions through children that they've
lost the capacity to just simply asked
the question is this really in my
interest or in the interest of the child
because the moment we begin to ask that
question is it whose interest is this
the parent will at that point decide
that teacher should be backed up ra
rather than the child and it seems to me
that all the problems that we be
discussing have got nothing to do with
parenting they got to do with the
cultural pressures that are upon the
parents where parents are asked to pick
up the pieces that have been caused
anywhere else and I just one fin
point I don't know what's the best way
of bringing up a child and I don't
particularly care how you do it as long
as you're happy with that but the one
thing that I do know that we learned
throughout the
centuries and that is that the principal
accomplishment of child rearing of
really good child rearing the principal
accomplishment of that is the capacity
to prepare your children for
Independence and if you've done that and
if you made your child gen independent
then you've done a good job and that's
really what we should be assessing
rather than all these other
[Applause]
stuff on it
sorry thank you very much Frank though
for giving me that seemed to be an
argument for the other side Western
parents not so good at parenting but
never mind Theodore well yes ladies and
gentlemen I'm very pleased that Frank
agrees with us so
much um please give two minutes so I'll
get started that oh I will I'll I'll
make it even briefer I think the uh if I
may say the real problem that I see is
that people do not make a distinction
between self-esteem and self-respect and
self-esteem is something that people
feel that they are intitled to and it's
a kind of human right whereas
self-respect is something uh that you
earn and is other
regarding and on the whole I think we
have instilled and I'm of course
speaking Gro Modo uh we have instilled
too uh too great an idea that people
should be filled with self-esteem when
actually what people need is
self-respect and that is where our our
um our child raring is I think uh rather
deficient not in every
case
okay now you've all voted I can come out
for it no um so so I just want to say
very quickly I want to say a word for
the Youth um our teens they volunteer
more than any other sector in society
nine out of 10 believe school workor is
important they're not all hoodied
terrifying knife wielding rap music kind
of singers um you know I had a TV in my
room um I very rarely at a family meal
and when I did they were hideous I mean
you know it was just a control freakery
thing by my dad um so I think um we
should all relax a bit I think if your
child is going through a thing it's
probably only a phase I think parenting
is horses for courses and above all I
think we should maintain a sense of
humor most of parenting although it's
very hard work uh when it's when you're
kept up late at night is quite a using
possibly with the exception of violin
practice and
[Applause]
headlice well I agree with so much of uh
what everybody said including the
opposition um the the chilling and also
I think it's important to have a sense
of humor about uh about parenting which
is uh partly one reason I really like
Justine's book I actually think uh just
to be able to laugh at our own mistakes
but I wanted to end with one anecdote
which which relates to the last two
questions about how do we how can we not
be tiger moms given the state of things
and this is from the United States but
one of the more touching emails I uh
I've had a lot like this but I remember
this one because it said she wrote me
and she said I may sound totally
different from you but I think I'm a
tiger mom I am Irish polish I am a
single mom I am a cop and I work two
jobs and I don't get home till 8:30 p.m.
so I couldn't possibly do math and
violin and piano with my kids
but I think that I'm a tiger mom and the
reason for that is because when I drag
myself home at 8:30 I tell my daughters
let me see those homework assignments I
look at the tests I say why did you miss
those who are your friends know you
can't go out with those people know you
can't date that guy and she said I was
known as the meanest mom in the
neighborhood and it was a bad
neighborhood and I did this I did this
because I myself got pregnant at 15 and
I suffered through a lot of misery and I
didn't want that for my girls and I'm
proud because I broke the cycle both my
daughters went to college I was a tiger
mom and I broke the cycle so I think
that's just to the point of oh is it all
about ourselves or is it for our kids I
think parents maybe not always but
parents can sometimes make a huge
difference and when you make that
difference I think that's when you get
the kind of feeling that I have as an
adult will you look back when you were a
kid you're cranky why are you so mean
but as an adult you look back and you
think oh my God I have a great life now
and I owe my parents everything so I
think we should owe I think we should
assume strength rather than fragility in
our children and I think that we in the
west totally agreeing with Justine
without going to the extreme of Asia
they have all maybe more problems than
we do but without going to that extreme
I think that we in the West can ask a
little more of our children and that
they will not only respond to that
challenge but thrive thank
[Applause]
you we're still waiting for the very
Speedy um tellers to come in with the
result of the vote so um while we're
waiting that I just wanted to raise the
question of the lady up at the top I
feel rather guilty about that she was
asking whether we should be worried that
at a time of economic stringency we're
going to end up with um less money
available to teach skills to children
and um I think that matters a great deal
partly because of some research that I
came across last week um which is done
by a famous Nobel Prize wi winning
Economist James Heckman in America and
he was quoting a famous study done 40
years ago amongst um deprived three and
four year- olds which took kids who
didn't have an order and structure in
their lives and taught them to do the
kind of things that tiger parents do and
a lot of middle- class parents do
automatically which is to all plan what
you're going to do do it and then review
it and it's quite a simple program but
it's very intense
40 years later the children who had been
through that program who were children
with below average IQs from very
deprived backgrounds were earning more
had more chance of owning their own home
were less likely to be pregnant or obese
um and can't remember the other
characters had had committed far fewer
crimes than the control group of
children who hadn't had that kind of
practice now that is exactly the kind of
um thing that the sh Start program was
originally meant to do in Britain and of
course there's now going to be a lot
less money available for that kind of
program so I'd just like to ask the
panel whether they're worried that it
may not be the middle classes the kind
of people who are represented here
tonight um who are really going to be
troubled about the fine distinctions
between tiger parenting and
authoritative parenting on the other but
are a whole lot of kids going to suffer
if we don't have that kind of training
available Amy I wondered what your view
was um well I I don't know Britain
system too much but that was in a way
part of my anecdote about the the Irish
polish single mom I mean that's kind of
what I was to trying to drive home that
um some people just don't have a choice
you know they don't have the same amount
of choices and um if you're not going to
get it from society um you kind of have
to do it yourself and the the I just
don't know your system well enough for
me the parallel is the American story
it's that first generation of immigrants
among I've had so many mean mean emails
but among the very supportive emails
it's surprising I they're
disproportionate from first generation
immigrants kids so kids from you know my
mom was from my parents are from Ghana
from Nigeria from Jamaica from Haiti no
money um uh but these we're even luckier
in some ways than the kids you're
talking about because they came with
sort of Education in their heads you
know but still no money no resources and
these are I found these are where the
tiger parents are concentrated in some
ways because they really have no choice
you know they they want their children
to be able to survive uh have a better
life and uh there's not a lot of luxury
nobody they can hire they got to do it
themselves
Theodore are you worried about the cuts
um well I'm not worried about the cuts
I'm worried about the Deep Corruption of
our public
administration um that sounds like quite
a
tangent because the vast majority of
what passes for public expenditure has
no connection with any ostensible
purpose as I know from working in the
National Health
Service and therefore when the cuts come
I can assure you that it will not be to
those parts of the uh
organization uh that are not needed
it'll be to those parts of the
organization that are
needed and uh if you count that as being
worried well then I'm worried thank you
I think I'll count that as worry at a
very deep level um
Justine I actually think there is um you
know it when you're talking about people
who um are stuck in the lower echelons
and have very little ambition um how
you're going to get those children out
of those echelons then I do think
actually parenting that is where I think
parenting really does matter um when you
haven't got the peer groups around you
haven't got um you know the the the sort
of learned history of parents teaching
parents hurt a parent and that's where I
think government does need to intervene
I think if you look at um kids who are
failing from families who are you know
in poor soci anomic classes and having
very little um success
generationally um then you know you find
that one of the things is they they just
don't praise their kids at all there's a
lot of negative Vibes and just having a
class which says this is the value of
being positive and not negative um you
know could be incredibly helpful so I
don't think it takes a lot of money but
I think it would be very useful Frank a
final word before we discover the result
yeah I think all the evidence shows that
parenting classes sh start any of these
programs simply don't work and I don't
think there's any uh magical reason for
that the reason for that is that there
are things in life that you have to
learn but cannot be taught right you
have to learn how to have good
relationships but at the end of the day
that's not something that something that
somebody else can teach you and the
problem that we have in our society is
not that there aren't enough sh Start
programs or parenting classes because I
think they are they really are about
socializing parents rather than children
that's really what their objective is
the real problem is that we don't
provide people from poorer backgrounds
with stimulating educational
opportunities that if you go into some
schools in this country it's like you
know sort of a dead end as far as the
children are concerned that right from
the very beginning there's an assumption
that they're going to fail in life and
instead of trying to solve uh a wide
social and cultural problem with the
parent which is entirely inappropriate
we we should look at the wider Community
setting and see what we can do there to
create a better opportunities for
children to be stimulated and challenged
in the way that's not the case at the
moment thank you very
much and now now I'd just like to um
announce the final result which I think
is rather astonishing I'd like to remind
you that before the debate 149 people
voted for the motion 325 are against and
the don't knows amounted to
194 well Minds have really been changed
because now it's 35 for the motion 280
against and only 59 don't
[Applause]
knows so i' just like to say thank you
all for coming and to the panel for
being such a lively
group